vous avez un smartphone de au poète vous
voulez savoir comment mieux utiliser
color es12 ou alors vous en avez pareil
vous vous dites maintien ça
m'intéresserait mais est ce que
l'expérience logiciel est intéressante
elle a justement aujourd'hui on va
regarder les nouveautés ce qu'on peut
venir faire avec coloro s12 basé sur un
android 12 ans vous avez déjà fait une
vidéo peu comme ça l'année dernière où
je vous parlais des nouveautés de
colorer 11 peut toujours aller la voir
je voulais un lien soit par la soie en
bas dans la description aller jeter un
petit coup d'oeil on va regarder
aujourd'hui ce conte et peuvent faire
ici avec son smartphone alors celui que
j'ai pris et bien c'est un find x5 pro
voilà tout mignon tout beau d'ailleurs
le test est déjà en ligne vous pourrez
aller jeter un petit coup d'oeil on va
regarder ce qu'on est capable de faire
première chose et ça on s'en doutera ce
que font les constructeurs lorsqu'ils
sortent de nouvelles expériences
logiciel est bien servir à améliorer un
petit peu les icônes jouer sur la
transparence alors ne vous y méprenez
pas ce que vous voyez ici a tout de
suite là sur les trans et
l'enregistrement de l'écran parce que
j'enregistre vous puissiez voir à
travers les caméras mais aussi
directement par vent de peser pour qu'on
va qu'on a une nouvelle icône
retravailler ses mignons c'est sympa
c'est sexy c'est beau c'est design et
s'est dessiné par opoa c'est un petit
peu le truc donc ça c'est un peu le
préambule prémices le premier détail
mais surtout l'idée là tu sais qu'on
peut aller très très loin en termes de
personnalisation regarder ce fidèle dans
ses paramètres et c'est déjà la
pérennisation c'est un truc qui
vachement important chez o pour l'avait
déjà vu l'année dernière ils vont encore
plus loin cette année s'est basé sur
matériel you matériel ou d'android ou
souvenez-vous l'idée c'est de faire
match et via votre fond d'écran avec la
couleur de vos icônes avec pourquoi pas
une photo vous auriez pris de vous avec
une tenue vestimentaire pourquoi avec la
tenue de votre jour vous fassiez match
et les icônes et compagnie c'est assez
marrant alors est-ce qu'on peut venir
faire garder je vous montre on peut
venir par exemple aller dans votre fond
d'écran et là j'ai choisi un fond
d'écran animé choisir un fond d'écran
statique par exemple un celui là et là
hop là je l'appliquent je le mets aux
deux c'est mignon c'est sympa donc là ça
me l'appliqué ok vous pouvez faire avec
n'importe quelle photo et ensuite ce que
vous faites c'est que vous venez ici et
vous allez donc couleurs qu'est ce qui
se passe dans couleurs et bien de
pouvoir venir choisir sont des
déclinaisons que vous avez ici soit
carrément sélection de couleurs de fond
d'écran ce que je vous conseille de
faire donc là il va venir rechercher
pour vous proposer des teintes extraites
de votre image pourrait bien vous après
déplace eh ben non moi je préfère
envoyer ce petit marronner là où je peux
ce petit orange l'a un peu plus un peu
plus clair alors carrément du orange
foncé donc vous choisissez c'est vous
qui avez la main là dessus et ensuite
vous cliquez sur ok et en cliquant sur
ok qu'est ce que ça va faire eh bien ça
va vous mettre vous différentes couleurs
en fonction de la couleur de votre image
et ça c'est plutôt sympa on ressort
voyez là déjà ça a changé on a un bleu
un peu plus clair et puis on peut faire
ça exactement avec plein de photos
différentes si par exemple je vous
prends ça où on va voir quoi la salle
avec des couleurs aussi un peu pétantes
tac je choisis je le sélectionne on va
dans couleurs pareil aube sélection là
il va travaux de recherche intelligente
mais je peux venir le bouger je fais ok
et ensuite regardé je reviens au plat et
là j'ai des couleurs rouge pour servir
tout le personnaliser tout va être
vraiment optimisé en fonction des choix
que j'ai fait là et ça c'est vachement
sympa donc bien le faire avec une photo
de vous de votre famille de votre maison
que vous voulez ou alors carrément avec
différents fonds d'écran silva chement
bien donc ça s'inspirait de matériel you
maintenant on peut venir faire aussi
autre chose au niveau de la
personnalisation c'est au niveau du hall
aux oiseaux display alors pour ceux qui
ne sauraient pas le hall voisin display
g ce qui s'affiche sur un écran et un
dos lorsqu'on le voit tout le temps fait
always on display toujours à l'écran je
prends au jeu déverrouille et donc
l'appareil de la même manière je peux
dire complètement personnalisé mon
always on display alors c'est assez
marrant parce que soit je peux le faire
comme je faisais l'année dernière c'est
à dire que j'ai un motif je fais des
petits dessins voyez plus j'en fais plus
on crée jojo mais d'autres couleurs ça
me rajoute donc hop là on va se mettre
un petit peu de rouge donc il ya un côté
un peu rigolo donc on peut vraiment
venir c'est lorsqu'on veut donc ça on
l'avait déjà vu l'année dernière mes
lampes aller plus loin c'est à dire que
par exemple on peut se mettre un texte
allez on va se mettre un petit texte on
va se marquer
monsieur hop là greu je peux mettre
plusieurs lignes si je veux je peux dire
choisir la couleur sur mon texte allez
on va se mettre ça la taille du texte
plus ou moins grand pour ça ça marche la
ligne bon droit de gauche l'espacement
entre les lignes bref on peut aller
vraiment loin et ensuite on applique on
applique alors de la même manière
j'éteins mon smartphone je tape dessus
always on display sont là ici monsieur
heureux et voyez c'est assez marrant
donc ça c'est bien on peut le faire
effectivement on le voit avec une
écriture mais on peut aller encore plus
loin regarder c'est hyper hyper sympa ça
c'est vraiment vous pouvez faire le hold
up display y met carrément avec
une silhouette de portraits c'est ce que
vous avez juste ici silhouette de
portrait c'est à dire que vous cliquez
vous allez venir chercher une petite
photo dans votre caméra l'on attend dé
nous vaut mieux chercher une photo on a
ça hop là donc là ça va venir me trouver
ma tête alors je vais me sens très un
petit peu voilà et ensuite je fais
généré donc là il ya un peu dia qui va
venir rechercher a les traits qui va
repérer tient cette vieille personne
vous allez voir le dessin se faire
directement donc la sarre perd un peu
les proportions et la voyais ma tronche
c'est y perdront alors je peux choisir
la couleur à pareille ça c'est pour mon
texte allez on va se mettre ça et je
mets appliquée et lorsque je viens ici
donc là j'ai ma photo on n'est pas
obligé on peut le mettre juste sur
l'oiseau display grade et j'éteins je
tape dessus et là j'ai ma tronche
derrière alors mon lit d'espagne or ma
tronche derrière mais on peut mettre un
portrait de ses enfants un portrait de
qui on veut de ses amis son amoureux
sont amoureuses peu importe son ça
vachement sympa et toujours dans l'idée
de la personnalisation de ce que nous
fait au pot ici et je trouve ça vraiment
vraiment cool alors un autre qui est
vachement bien au niveau de la sécurité
la confidentialité
si par exemple il n'ya pas d'application
qui vont vous demander votre
géolocalisation et il ya des
applications il faut l'utiliser
notamment sur d'hubert rue mérite ce
tout ce qui va être taxi s'ils ont pavé
localisation ça marche pas mais
également sur des applis de météo mais
pour autant j'ai pas envie qu'ils
sachent exactement je suis alors hubert
pour bien vous cherchez c'est quand même
mieux mais sur une météo vous soyez là
où à 300 m 400 m et un moment on s'en
fiche donc y'a un truc qui est vachement
bien vous allez ici dans confidentialité
vous allez dans gestionnaire
d'autorisation vous allez dans lieux et
vous allez dans n'importe quelle
application au genre google que vous
avez là et là vous avez un truc qui est
bien et sait utiliser la position exacte
alors si vous décochez et bien il y aura
une position moins exacts un peu plus
imprécise à regarder si la position
exacte est désactivé les applis aux
accès à votre position approximative
comme ça elles seront pas exactement où
est ce que vous êtes un instant t c'est
vraiment pour venir protégez-vous venir
garantir votre confidentialité même si
les services de météo vont pas utiliser
votre adresse pour bien vous voir ou
visiter mais néanmoins on n'a pas
toujours envie de partager ça et ça
paraît normal donc pour les applis dont
c'est vraiment important moi par exemple
google jeunesse active et pourquoi parce
que gmail google docs google doit savoir
que je suis là pour désactiver la
surveillance lorsque je suis là et
l'activé lorsque je ne suis pas là ça
c'est de façon complètement automatique
donc là google ait un sens mais il ya
des habous n'avait absolument pas besoin
donc ça c'est vachement bien aussi
autres apps qui est vachement
intéressant c'est une notion traduction
instantanée par exemple vous arrivez sur
un site et vous ne parlez pas la langue
on va aller chez hop au point cn je ne
parle pas chinois clairement je ne
comprends rien ce qui est écrit ici donc
vous avez une petite barre latérale hop
là que vous voulez chercher et juste ici
si vous regardez vous avez de la
traduction d'écran donc je clique sur
traduction d'écran l'ours est basé sur
google n 5 qui va venir chercher dans
plus de 100 langues et ça fait quoi bein
ça vient de traduire alors des fois du
chinois aux français c'est assez
imparfait mais sur d'autres langues ça
marchera très très bien voyez par
exemple si j'ai bien regardé ici je vais
avoir partagé les nouvelles service
client moments intéressants photographié
au hasard le printemps arrive sans
astuce pour jouer avec les téléphones
portables f j'ai une trad et ça c'est
plutôt bien c'est très rapide envoyé en
un clic voilà je vous ai fait le coup du
chinois mais vous pouvez faire avec de
l'anglais de l'allemand plus de 100
langues ce que vous voulez donc ça c'est
cool il ya un autre truc est vachement
intéressant parce que on voit pas tous
les couleurs de la même manière donc là
ce qu'on voit c'est très normé c'est
pour monsieur madame tout le monde il ya
des personnes qui ont soit des
pathologies soit qu'ils ne voient pas
les couleurs un peu comme les autres et
bien vous allez ici dans affichage et
luminosité vous descendez dans mode
couleurs de l'écran qui est situé juste
là est juste en bas gardez vous le
propose amélioration de la vision des
couleurs alors vous cliquez là dessus et
vous pouvez venir activer sa
amélioration de la vision des couleurs
et là vous allez avoir différentes
différentes propositions alors soit une
nuance de gris si les couleurs c'est pas
du tout votre truc m'ont parlé sur du
noir et blanc on va avoir un filtre
rouge donc là il vraie différence déjà
qui va ce plat le filtre vert donc là
les rouges sont moins forts voyez là les
rouges seront plus forts la filtre bleu
et puis l'a carrément personnalisé vous
pour tester de la vision des couleurs on
clique là et comme ça on peut venir voir
alors optimiser les couleurs par teinte
touché la couleur qui ressemble plus à
la couleur précédentes vous voyez c'est
celle là pour moi ça plus de verges de
celles là et puis ensuite on y va de 1
an 1 là on va se rapprocher un petit
singe pense à ça ça ça c'est vachement
dur en fait c'est vraiment un exercice
qui est pas simple je dirais ça ça ça
valait 2 pour moi c'est quasiment les
mêmes parce qu'ils voyaient après des
travaux caméras c'était plus vieux que
je suis là
ouah celui-là est celui-là voilà vous
voyez confirmés et là j'ai fait mon test
tests terminés les couleurs sont
maintenant ajuster en fonction de votre
vision des couleurs donc ça c'est
vachement vachement vachement vachement
bien en fonction des besoins de chacun
et de la vision qu'on va tout savoir
regarder se désactive il ya quand même
une différence par rapport à ce qu'on
voit large pas si vous le verrez bien
comme ça mais si je vous le mets comme
ça ça c'est ce que je vois moi tac ben
il ya quand même une différence là c'est
beaucoup plus pétant et là c'est un peu
plus neutre autre outil qui est
intéressant c'est des fois on va te le
smartphone rame un peu on dit un truc
qui a un look qui marchent pas et on
veut venir optimisé pas ce que vous
faites et vous venez juste là dans
outils d'un outil vous avez une app qui
s'appelle gestionnaire du téléphone vous
cliquez là et là il vous propose
d'optimiser votre smartphone moi je vois
que risque détecté optimisation de vos
systèmes qui me propose de venir au
petit musée je clique sur optimisée et
là il va nettoyer il va regarder toutes
les notions de confidentialité deux
protections pour arriver à une
optimisation à 100% selon lui est
terminée et il est venu beau c'est
pourquoi il m'est encore en 95 et
pensant allez savoir parce que détecter
optimiser votre système bon il ya un
autre truc qui est extrêmement important
lorsqu'on utilise son smartphone sur la
question de la confidentialité on va se
dire ou es ce que mon micro est activée
mais qui avait réactivé auprès des
couteaux peux me regarder quelles
applications utilisant même si autant on
peut le voir parce que les constructeurs
ont vraiment un très gros boulot niveau
logiciel même google derrière sur la
plateforme android mais des fois on
voudrait dire allez je clique j'ai fait
sûr que c'est couper la garde et vous
descendez ici là dans votre centre de
contrôle et vous venez sur le côté droit
jazeera joue-t-elle et pouvait venir
voulais rajouter alors moi je les ai
mises juste là axé votre caméra avec
sonic aura des jeux cliquer là je clique
l'aop caméras et micros sont
complètement coupés d'un point de vue
logiciel on peut plus venir à les
utiliser je vais regarder essayé
d'activer ma caméra et voyez il me marc
débloquer l'appareil photo de l'appareil
soit débloquée soit à new york sur des
blocs et ça me débloque mais par défaut
ils étaient bloqués et voyez lorsque je
reviens dans mon centre de notifier la
et ben ma caméra est les nouveaux actifs
parce que je les débloquer je vais
réactiver le micro alors si vous vous
les avez pas il faut vous cliquez ici là
sur le petit icône là et là vous et
l'art des icônes qui ne sont pas
utilisés elle était juste à droite je
clique là et je dis glisse voilà comme
ça je les mets dans mon rôle de contrôle
et puis si je veux les enlever pareil
demain de même bien je le prends et je
le remets en bas extrêmement facilement
donc ça s'est très très bien il ya un
autre mode qui existent je peux pas vous
le montrez là c'est ce qu'ils
appelleront le mode anti regards et les
modes anti regard il parce que lorsque
vous recevez un sms et que vous le
regardez bien vous affiche le message ou
si vous avez un mois de ça pour un truc
un petit peu confidentielle un petit peu
chaud allez savoir ce qui se passe en
fait c'est que s'il ya de l'ia derrière
qui est votre cas graves au détecteur de
visages qui regardent paraiba là le
message est masquée sous marque vous
avez eu notification whatsapp vous avez
reçu un sms pas plus par mois ça avait
un peu sécurisé l'histoire donc ça s'est
très très bien et puis un dernier point
qui est super important si vous avez un
pc que vous voulez faire communiquer
avec votre smartphone vous montrer la
joute prendre pc ici et vous allez voir
comment ça marche vous téléchargez
l'application qui s'appelle pc connect
vous cherchez sur google un pc collecte
au pot vous allez finir la trouver
regardez la plage déverrouille mon pc
donc là je suis sur mon pc alors j'ai
mon apicil apc connect qui est installé
directement sur mon pc vous voyez c'est
celle là donc la tac je clique dessus et
je louvre donc là je l'avais déjà
connectés mon fils dit que cinq pros
donc il connaît mais si vous le
connaissez pas il va faire une petite
recherche ça se connecte en bluetooth en
fait hein vous laissez votre bluetooth
connectés et là vous venez dans votre
smartphone et dans votre smartphone
venez regarder vous avez ça s'appelle
comment en français c'est multi screen
connect voilà il est connecté et ensuite
j'ai plus qu'à faire connecte
directement dans l'application donc il
va venir à se connecter directement à
lorsque à l'égard des fautes et que voir
appuie là où faucheux l'autorisent ils
me demandent l'autorisation je me
connecte directement au pc et là je vais
récupérer directement avec son
smartphone sur mon pc haut de la même
manière si je bouge là ça bouge là ça je
vous l'avais déjà montré à cowes cherché
ouais c'est le même système en fait vous
prenez pour naviguer directement ici
rentrer dans vos applications pour taper
directement et des sms depuis votre
ordinateur activer la caméra prendre des
photos parce que vous prenez votre
caméra vous la posez pas distance bien
vous shooter à partir de votre pc vous
pouvez naviguer sur votre smartphone
directement depuis votre pc faire des
copier coller récupérer des éléments là
par exemple je vais dans photo allez une
petite photo qui est là je l'apprends
hop je la glisse là et je l'envoie
directement et voyez la joie de la voir
sur mon bureau elle a atterri juste ici
il ya un côté qui est vraiment hyper
hyper sympa avec cette fonctionnalité là
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui
rapportent en plus parce que une fois de
plus ce qui est très important c'est une
notion d'écosystème vous avez un pc vous
avez un smartphone aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de pc de oppose donc le fait que
vous avez un smartphone vous puissiez le
connecter avec un windows 10 sous
windows c'est vachement bien voilà c'est
pour ça il ya quelques astuces et
nouveautés de color os doux basé sur un
android ou suis très heureux d'avoir
plus les partager avec vous qui bien
évidemment n'oubliez pas les astuces que
je vous ai donné l'année dernière de
coloriste 11 reste complètement valable
sur votre smartphone si vous souhaitez
les découvrir je vous mets le lien bien
évidemment quelque part dans la
description aller jeter un oeil parce
que je trouve que cette expérience
logiciels chez au pot elle fonctionne
vraiment bien pareil au niveau de la
capture d'écran spa tout nouveau ça vous
prenez trois doigts up et vous descendez
ça vous fait une capture d'écran vous
avez trois doigts appareils de la même
manière vous appuyez vous laisser et
vous descendez jusqu'en bas vous pourrez
faire une capture d'écran l'ombre à ses
passagers sur la page d'accueil bref il
ya vachement de choses c'est bien c'est
personnalisé et c'est vraiment une
solution que je trouve extrêmement
intéressante qui a le matériel non je
viens mais il ya également le logiciel
ça c'est chouette dites moi ce que vous
en pensez puis faisait des questions
d'autres astuces à venir partager sur un
smartphone de au pot marqué le mois en
commentaire et puis dites moi si ça vous
intéresse que je vous fasse d'autres
vidéos d'astuces pour d'autres marques
sur les films sur samsung apps a
longtemps j'en ai également sur un
iphone mais ça peut être pour remy pour
schumi pour toutes les autres marques
qui existent marquer le moment
commentaires et nous on se retrouve très
vite pour continuer à parler d'elle pour
le soin de vous j'embrasse et beaucoup
d'amour
[Musique]
m